tear them out while show after the media
spent days blaming me and other
conservatives for the gay club shooting
in Colorado we are now being told that
the shooter is a non-binary they them
interesting also the Daily Coast is uh
forced to retract an egregious lie they
told about me it is possible apparently
to hold these left-wing organizations
accountable which is a lesson that we on
the right need to learn plus Joy Reid
airs footage from a drag queen Story
Hour hoping to prove that the events are
actually appropriate for children but
instead proving the opposite a woman
blames Universal Studio for the fact
that she was too fat to fit on the
roller coasters and finally someone very
close to me must be canceled in today's
tragic daily cancellation all of that
and more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
I've spent this whole week hearing about
how I am responsible for a mass shooting
in Colorado this always seemed strange
to me as I never committed any mass
shooting and I wasn't even in Colorado
in the night in question so my alibi
checks out but I am responsible anyway
they said because I inspired the psycho
who walked into a gay club on Saturday
and killed five people I inspired him so
did Chris Ruffo and Tucker Carlson and
Libs of tick tock and others we inspired
him specifically by being too openly
opposed to the sexualization and
castration of children
and such a view apparently inspires
murderous rage in people
now as I've argued over the last few
days this accusation which has been made
against us by every major media outlet
and by thousands of random leftist ogres
online is absurd and inane and baseless
and designed to Blackmail us into
accepting the less abusive children
that and it's also an accusation being
made in spite of the fact that we hadn't
yet been told anything specific about
the shooter or his actual motivations
there was a conspicuous Gap in the story
now most of the time after a mass
shooting we know the shooter's whole
life story within like 30 minutes his
social media posts begins circulating
and everything else and this is
especially the case if the shooter is
right wing
if that's the case then we hear all
about his right wing posts his
right-wing statements his Manifesto is
published and picked over we'll know
which right-wing media personalities he
followed on Twitter or retweeted we will
know all of that
and yet in this case even though the
media insisted that the shooter is a
right-wing radical inspired by dastardly
conservative figures like myself
strangely enough we were never given any
specific information to support that
claim
this in spite of the fact that he had
been taken alive and has been
interviewed by investigators even still
we were never told anything about his
own stated motives or anything else
about his actual life
the only things we knew for sure were
some background details such as the fact
that this guy uh the same guy was
arrested for threatening to blow up his
house last year we also knew that his
grandfather was an obscure low-level
Republican politician a fact which is
supposed to prove something but which of
course proves nothing as it's not
exactly unheard of that a member of gen
Z might have different politics from his
grandfather it also came to light that
the shooter's mother is a drug addict
and criminal with multiple warrants for
her arrest and his estranged father is a
former MMA fighter and Drug Smuggler who
became a porn star who goes by the stage
name dick Delaware
so what was emerging was a picture of a
deranged demented young man from a
broken home and a tumultuous upbringing
who lashed out violently in a way that
can be partially blamed on many exigent
factors all having to do with the way he
was raised and none having to do with
this podcast or a Libs of tick tock
tweets
but then last night another detail
emerged a detail that may explain why we
have heard surprisingly little about the
shooter up until now despite the shooter
being portrayed as an avowed right
winger inspired by conservatives
according to the media we've not
actually been given any evidence any
evidence at all to support that
assertion and now perhaps we know why
the Denver Post reports quote
the person's suspected of killing five
and wounding 18 after opening fire in a
gay nightclub in Colorado Springs is
non-binary their defense attorney wrote
in court filings Tuesday Joseph
arkenbald and Michael Bowman the state
public defender for suspect Anderson Lee
Aldrich filed a slew of motions Tuesday
and included a footnote about aldrich's
identity quote Anderson Aldrich is
non-binary the footnote says they use
they them pronouns and for the purposes
of all formal filings will be addressed
as mix Aldrich MX Eldridge
and there it is a non-binary they them
with a porn star father
not exactly my target audience
now why would someone who identifies
that way attack a gay bar well for many
reasons potentially it's not at all
unheard of for a member of the LGBT
community to attack their own community
in fact it just happened elsewhere in
the country this week in New York City
it was revealed that the culprit who had
been smashing windows on a gay bar in
Hell's Kitchen is a gay man with some
kind of personal grudge against the bar
of course the media in that case also
assumed right away this is a right-wing
hate attack now there was a gay guy
could that be the case in Colorado
Springs Maybe
could it be that this guy was spurned or
rejected by somebody at the club and was
lashing out for that reason again maybe
it's quite plausible I don't know could
he have some other personal reason maybe
we don't know we may never know and
because not only the media but local law
enforcement and the Attorney General of
the state have all gone on the record
predicting that this was a right-wing
crime
it seems likely to me that they'll find
a way to force that motivation onto this
guy whether it's true or not
I wouldn't be surprised if we hear in
the next few days that he has uh
recanted his non-binary status after
some
shall we say persuasion from the powers
that be
wouldn't surprise me
meanwhile the corporate media is
fumbling around for a way to handle this
new revelation on CNN last night these
stunned and nearly speechless news
anchor
simply decided that she wasn't going to
accept the Revelation at all that's how
she's handling it she's just not going
to accept it uh and let's watch that
moment
so attorneys for the accused shooter
Anderson Lee Aldrich say in new court
filings tonight that the suspect now
identifies as non-binary
in a footnote to a motion asserting
legal privileges the public defenders
say quote Anderson Aldrich is non-binary
they use they them pronouns and for the
purposes of all formal filings will be
addressed as mix Aldrich so in other
words not Mr or Miz joining me now CNN
political commentator Errol Lewis also
back with me Al Franken and Joe Walsh I
don't know what to say about that I mean
that's not anything that we had heard
from his background you know people have
been looking into his background and I
don't know if anybody here are you guys
lawyers
I mean you know I don't know if I I
don't know what to say about that I mean
that's what he's now saying it sounds
like they're trying to prepare a defense
against a hate crimes charge that's the
least of his problems legally speaking
but it looks like they're trying to
build some kind of sympathy or at least
confusion on the question of whether or
not this was purely motivated by hate I
mean that is what it sounds like we'll
wait to see
hmm
listen to all the misgendering shameful
now
it's possible that the shooter did in
fact discover his inner non-binary truth
as a convenient way of trying to avoid
hate crime charges that's a possible
scenario
though there are plenty of reasons to
doubt such a theory beginning with the
fact that a person who commits a violent
hate crime is not likely to assume the
identity of the group he hates
I mean was the last time you heard about
an anti-semitic shooter killing Jewish
people and then converting to Judaism to
avoid the hate crime charge two days
later
um part of the point of the crime in a
case like that is to make a statement
that's why a lot of times there's a
Manifesto that goes along with it it's
difficult to make the statement when
you're immediately identifying yourself
with the group that you slaughtered
also avoiding the hate crime charge
offers no benefit the Killer is going to
spend the rest of his life in prison no
matter what whether convicted of a hate
crime or convicted simply of five counts
of regular old first degree murder
doesn't benefit from it you're going to
prison for the rest of your life and
there's no other option because in
Colorado they don't have the death
penalty but this is all essentially
irrelevant
the point is that first of all
first of all
the left has no right to deny anyone's
self-identity that is the rule they
established and they must be held to it
these same people would insist that even
when a male sex offender suddenly comes
out as a woman while in prison we may
not even speculate about the possibility
that is trans Awakening might have been
motivated by a desire to gain access to
female inmates and when a man identifies
as a woman and next thing you know he's
disrobing in a woman's locker room we
may not even speculate that his trans
identification is fueled at least in
part by his desire to gain access to
naked women
there are many self-serving reasons why
a person might call themselves trans or
non-binary what we know for sure is that
they aren't calling themselves trans or
non-binary because they actually are
trans or non-binary since no such
category exists in biological reality it
is a made-up invented human-made
category so there's always going to be
some other reason be it mental illness
or something more calculated and
self-serving self-serving I know that
and you know that
but the left
denies everything I just said which
means that they have no basis for
refusing to respect the shooter's
non-binary identity as far as their
ideology is concerned if he says he's a
they then he's a they and that's all
there is to it
that is their belief
that's the precedent that they on the
left have set and we will for damn
certain force them to live by it
anytime you hear someone on the left
well maybe you're not allowed to do that
you are not allowed to do that you do
not have the right to do it you can't
because according to you the only thing
necessary to prove that someone is nine
non-binary is for them to say that they
are non-binary that's it no other
evidence required no counter evidence is
allowed to be admitted
so if you're on the left you're stuck
again you set the precedent you have to
respect his identity I don't I don't
have to respect it and I don't I don't
respect anything about this guy but you
do
because these are your rules
so take your own medicine and choke on
it
second point
whatever else comes out about this guy
sorry this um them
we already know enough to know that the
media jumped to Wild and baseless
conclusions they did it without evidence
and in spite of the evidence that was
already known and they did it so quickly
and so furiously precisely so that they
could set the narrative before the truth
whatever the truth truth happens to be
comes out
they never cared about the victims
they are happy that those people were
killed this is what you have to
understand about the media if you don't
yet they are happy that it happened
their only regret is that Moore didn't
die to make this an even bigger story
because to the scarring
skulking little roaches in the media the
only thing that matters
is that this event gives them an
opportunity to slander and defame their
enemies
like me like Tucker Carlson like live to
tick tock Chris rufo Candice Owens Ben
Shapiro and others it's all that matters
to them
we're all owed apologies
I mean whatever else happens next we are
owed apologies but of course we'll never
get them we'll have to be satisfied with
the simple knowledge that those who seek
always to destroy us with lies and libel
are nothing but soulless charlatans and
bloodthirsty sociopaths who can barely
contain their orgasmic Glee whenever
there's a tragedy because it gives them
ratings and it gives them political
ammunition and those two things are the
only two things they care about in this
world
I consider it a great honor to be hated
so much by such loathsome disgusting
trolls as these
and I take solace in the knowledge that
they have nuked their own credibility so
that at this point their lives can only
convince a sad and dwindling collection
of the dumbest and most gullible idiots
to ever walk the face of the Earth
all the rest of us are impervious to
their propaganda
that's why the prop the corporate media
is dying
and will eventually be dead
and when it's finally dead we will dance
joyfully on its grave
the way they dance on the graves of mass
shooting victims
the only difference is that they will
deserve the desecration
now let's get to our five headlines
if we're going to change the culture we
need to reassess our spending habits and
start supporting like-minded companies
that's why you need to switch to the
pro-life pro-family cell phone company
Charity mobile Charity mobile has the
same great Nationwide mobile phone
service and coverage as other carriers
and they send five percent of your
monthly plan price to the pro-life
pro-family charity of your choice you
don't have to compromise on value or
service Charity mobile offers the latest
phones and tablets and Live customer
service based right here in the USA
while many other companies are bowing to
the woke mob by donating to pro-choice
causes and candidates or reimbursing
their employees travel expenses so that
they if they live and work in a pro-life
State they can travel to a pro-abortion
state get an abortion and be back at
work on Monday while they're doing that
Charity mobile continues to fight for
the right to life pro-life causes need
your continued support now through the
end of the year Charity mobile customers
get a free phone free activation free
shipping and free portable battery
charger while supplies last all you got
to do is mention offer code Walsh call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
Walsh that's charitymobile.com mention
code Walsh
of course talking about the lives from
the media uh I would be remiss if I
didn't mention none were more egregious
as I mentioned briefly yesterday than
the daily coasts which published a
headline yesterday
quoting me as saying that I wish more
people were killed at the gay club quote
it put it in quotes
they put it in Matt Walsh quote they put
that in quotes that I wish more people
were killed uh of course I never said
that or anything close to that but
leftist propaganda Rags like the Daily
Coast they have grown accustomed to just
sort of casually defaming conservatives
with no consequence
because that's the world they've been
living in for years they can just do
whatever they want and say whatever they
want and there is no consequence because
nobody ever holds them to anything
to any kind of standard
I mean conservatives have complained
about no one holds them to a standard
but then there was never any attempt to
make them abide by any standard
but that world is gone okay those days
are over
because I'm not going to tolerate it I
can tell you that
so I demanded a published published
retraction and correction they did when
I first pointed this out uh they pretty
quickly took the article down they just
deleted it
and and and uh they were hoping that
would be enough
but then I responded by saying no no you
can't just delete it okay you need to
retract it then you need to publish your
retraction and admit what you did
um and uh about an hour or so later they
did that they published uh they they
took the the headline down they put the
article back up without the headline and
said it now it says retracted and then
they have this note at the top in a
previous headline for this article we
misattributed a quote to Matt Walsh we
regret not properly quoting Walsh's
tweet this article is indirect violation
of our editorial policy and we have
removed it
now I must say that I do find it quite
pleasurable to think about how painful
it was for them to bend to my will and
give in to my demands and admit that
they lied about me that's got to be very
painful
like to have to do something that I said
that would be as painful for them as it
would be for me if I had to do something
with daily code can you imagine if the
Daily Coast demanded that I do something
that I say something and then I said it
like I would I'd rather be dead than
that I would choose death over that
that's how disgusting that thought is to
me
um and uh and yet they they uh for them
they didn't choose death before dishonor
they took the dishonor and they just
went ahead and published that which is
great
now true they don't apologize to me
directly
I could I could also still sue them
in fact they admit guilt in their
retraction that's the great part they
could have tried the claim keep in mind
they could have tried to claim that the
headline was uh you know worded
confusingly and it was it was being
misinterpreted or something that would
be a total nonsense of course but they
could have claimed that and obviously
they have no compunction about lying so
they so they they already lied in the
headline they could lie again to try to
get out of this uh pickle they put
themselves in
but they don't instead they admit that
they misattributed the quote to me so
you think they're they're Defenders on
the left when before they took the
article down their Defenders were saying
that no they're not even trying to quote
you you're you're lying about what the
Articles they're not quoting you that's
not with the intention
well they kind of pulled the rug out
from underneath their own Defenders by
saying yeah we misattributed the quote
to him that's what we did
leaving the door wide open for me to sue
them anyway
but whatever happens
the fact is they did backtrack not out
of any kind of ethical journalistic
standard okay so I don't want any of
this well give them some credit for
doing the right thing no no they did it
because I forced them to they had no
option
because they knew that I would get
lawyers involved and I would sue them
and I would win and so that's why they
did the right thing
all right
let's see let's move to this daily wires
reporting the National Hockey League
took some heat over a Tuesday tweet
promoting a transgender and non-binary
hockey tournament and a follow-up
comment asserting trans women are women
trans men are men non-binary identity is
real
the tournament in question the team
trans draft tournament took place over
the weekend in Middleton Wisconsin and
included only trans and non-binary
players
on Tuesday at the NH NHL's official
Twitter account shared several photos
from the tournament along with a
statement showing support for the event
said the NHL is is proud to support this
past weekend's team trans draft
tournament in Middleton Wisconsin this
was the first tournament uh comprised
entirely of transgender and non-binary
players with around 80 folks
participating
and then that's when they responded uh
to someone else saying that trans women
are women trans men are men non-binary
identity is real
what we have to understand is that every
institution and organization at this
point is basically run by blue-haired
liberal women
and gay liberal men like that's every
organization in America is either run
by such or is or as operates as though
it is
okay which is how you get the NHL
tweeting something that it sounds like
it's you know you you imagine a blue
haired 22 year old gender Studies major
saying that and this is what you're
getting from the NHL which used to be
I've never been a hockey fan
but I've always respected hockey at
least as a as a kind of rough and tumble
masculine sport
and even there
tweeting this stuff
trying to appeal to an audience that
will never be their customer base
like the people who
want to hear that kind of thing trans
women are women non-binary identities
are real like the the the the
demographic of people who find that sort
of thing appealing
this is a demographic that is not
watching hockey okay
and that's not even to say that nobody
no liberal identifying person watches
hockey I'm sure there are
but even they like they it's not going
to be the kind of liberal that needs to
hear you say that
so this is just these woke
uh institutions committing it's like
it's suicide it's self-destruction
you really don't gain anything from it
they're not they're not going to profit
off of this
and this isn't even a case you know
sometimes you have these these
organizations corporations that will go
woke
um in response to some sort of
controversy
so it would almost be it would still not
be justifiable but almost be a different
case if you had say I don't know some
NHL player who said something who who
dared to say out loud that um you know
women are women and men are men and then
was getting a lot of heat from it from
from uh from uh the media and then the
NHL responded by saying oh we don't
believe that we believe that trans women
are women so that would be a case of
them trying to dig themselves out of a
hole it would still be again
unjustifiable and a stupid thing to do
but you understand the motivation anyway
they're just cowardly trying to dig
themselves out of this PR Hole by um by
pandering to the left
but in this case it's an unforced error
like they could have just not tweeted
that you don't need to
no one needed to see you tweet that
the only thing you can hope to do is
alienate the audience you already have
because again you're not going to
attract
whatever audience it finds that kind of
statement really appealing you're not
you're not going to attract them and not
watching hockey
that's why wokeness it really does
especially when it comes to these
corporations it reminds me of Lies think
of this the other day
you know that uh
there's a certain kind of uh parasite
it's like a brain parasite and it's
Toxoplasma something or other that can
infest mice
and when when the mice are infested by
this parasite it causes the mice to be
suicidal actually makes them attracted
to cats and so they will run to their
own death
they will run into the into the the
mouths of a of a waiting cat that's
going to devour them uh they Embrace
their own destruction because that's the
parasite because the parasite really
wants to end up inside the cat and so
this is the the way that it's evolved
it's a really similar thing with with
Wellness I think it causes this kind of
self-destructive Instinct especially in
corporations they just run to their own
destruction
in a very similar kind of way yes
wokeness is a is a brain parasite maybe
the best way to describe it
speaking of people with brain parasites
Joy Reed attempted to defend drag queen
groomer hours by showing a video from
one that she attended and it does show
you how I mean out of touch just doesn't
even begin to describe it but it does
show you how out of touch these people
are
that she thinks that this she thinks
that you'll watch this
and then you'll come to the conclusion
that oh actually it's great to have a
combined kids and drag queens
let's see
and I just wanted before just to go on
because I don't think most people have
ever seen one I've been to one with kids
there with like kids there I want to
show you guys what drag queen story
hours look like because there was a drag
show at that was supposed to be at this
club uh when this attack happened I just
want those who don't know what they look
like to see what one looks like this is
cut two please play this
the hair so a lot of drag queens have
really big big big hair so the hair on
the drag queen goes up up up so you can
put your hands on your head like this
and go up up up
so the hair on the drag queen goes up up
up up up up up up up up up up up up the
hair on the drag queen goes up up up up
all through the town good job
and you know it it makes me sad Brandon
that that scares right-wing people so
much that they would try to ban it or
your Governor sued people over it and
then people act surprised when there's
violence against people who are trans
and lgbtq your thoughts
uh
yeah that's so she plays that and then
she's oh you have a problem with this
yeah we do that's yeah that's exactly
what we have a problem with
that's disturbing and weird and so
you've got to drag we got a man injury
you have a cross-dressing man who is
playing out his cross-dressing fetish
it's what it is and um and so and he's
singing about his fetish to kids uh to
the tune of the wheels on the bus
and and yeah are we scared of that um
I'm not personally scared of that guy in
the dress
okay I'm not I don't personally fear for
my physical safety because of him I I
feel pretty certain that I could
you know
handle it if uh if I was ever physically
threatened by a drag queen that's that's
that's
not
the issue
it's the kids and yeah I'm scared for
the kids
for their sake
I'm scared about them being exposed to
this kind of propaganda
I'm scared for them because someone
should be it is it is a scary thought
yes it is a it is actually a scary
thought
of children being brought into rooms to
be um
indoctrinated by drag queens
and you notice what she doesn't do like
we talked about yesterday
they continually insist that we defend
our
position
that it's inappropriate to bring drag
queens around children we can easily do
that drag queen drag is inherently
sexual it is burlesque for gay men that
is what it is that is what it is
historically that's what it's always
been and so it's not appropriate for
kids so we can explain that but what
they will not do is actually explain
why this is good like why we need to do
this so you've got a you've got a man
dressed in drag reading a story and
reading a song in the to the tune of uh
or singing a song to the tune of The
Wheels On The Bus why not just sing The
Wheels On The Bus
why can't you do that instead
answer me that Joy Reed what's wrong
with that what's wrong with The Wheels
On The Bus why can't you just sing that
song
instead of making it about drag queens
why not read sing about the damn School
Bus
as many generations of kids before these
kids already have
and if you want to have someone read
stories to Children sounds great to me
I'm all about reading stories to
children it's a very important thing for
their development is to sit them down
for story time and read them stories I
read books to my kids all the time
story time at the library very common
I attended story times at libraries when
I was a child but you know who read the
books the librarian
or someone like that very often it was a
woman like an actual woman who would
come out and read a book
and maybe do a sing-along
so that's the way it was done before
why can't you just do that why can't if
you if you want someone dressed like a
woman reading to kids why not an actual
woman why not a real one
how has it improved
by swapping out the woman for a guy
dressed like one
what is the added benefit there what's
the value added in your mind
they never explain it they can't explain
it they know they can't
because then they would have to say out
loud that the reason that they would
prefer the drag queen instead of The
Librarian Is that they have an
ideological and political agenda that is
not Advanced by having Librarians read
innocuous stories and sing songs about
school buses to kids
and anytime there are children gathered
they see it as an opportunity because
they are groomers they see us an
opportunity to groom the children and
indoctrinate them they say it's like
it's a wasted opportunity as far as
they're concerned the joy reads of the
world if you've got kids gathered at the
library it's a wasted opportunity if
you're not
um
using it as a chance to
you know disseminate LGBT propaganda
but they are so
lost at this point they are so lost
their souls have just been have been uh
have rotted away
to the point where they I actually
believe that they don't see it
like she she admits she brought a kid to
Dragon Story how she just she doesn't
even see what the problem is she does
not
intuitively see what the problem is with
having a man act out his cross-dressing
fetish in front of her children
every person on Earth would have
intuitively seen that up until recently
but um
for for people on the left especially
those who have been on the left for you
know are older now and have been living
this way for so long their moral
intuition
that kind of innate Instinct has it's
still there somewhere
somewhere deep inside but it's buried
deep in their subconscious somewhere
and they don't have immediate access to
it
and that's what makes conversation
between us so difficult
because they don't have this basic moral
intuition
or at least it's it's so deeply buried
and so that's why a lot of especially a
lot of just normal people you know even
if they don't identify as conservative
just normal people
who hear about drag queen Story Hour and
they object to it
and they're trying to talk to the left
and they say no of course we're not what
why would you have bring kids in front
of a drag queen
it's like it's it's oh it's almost hard
for them to explain because it's so
obvious
they never thought they would have to
explain that
all right
what else do we got here let's uh
we'll lighten the mood a little bit at
least this lightens meant for us uh this
is from Yahoo
says Imam says that her trip to
Universal Studios was ruined when she
couldn't go on any rides because they
weren't size inclusive
and uh they were trying out the test
seats in front of crowds of people with
no privacy which felt like an
embarrassing spectacle so this is a one
of the latest viral videos on Tick Tock
and
anyway instead of reading about it we'll
hear her tell the story of uh going to
she was victimized she says that she
says that uh Universal Studios is not
size inclusive
because of this experience that she had
let's listen
hi Tick Tock I'm going to tell you a
story about how this woman is too fat to
fit on any roller coasters at Universal
Studios
please know that I am under No Illusion
that I am thin I'm not I have an
hourglass body I have giant boobs my ass
and thighs are enormous
but what I am teaching my children and
what I am teaching the team of people
that I work with is that a body like
this is capable of climbing mountains
and of doing good things and even
capable of having pretty solid blood
work
which we would consider healthy right
so please know there is no fever dream
that exists where I think that I'm thin
or that I couldn't possibly stand to
lose some weight don't come for me in
the comments I already know
what I don't like is taking my daughter
on a girl's trip for her 13th birthday
um and not being able to spend time with
her
she had to write all of these roller
coasters alone because I was too fat to
fit into any of them I had to sit in the
test seat
um where ahead of me a very large man
had been able to make it click so I sat
in the test seat for the velocity
coaster
and it wouldn't click because of my hips
my thighs and my butt
um I was very disappointed I love roller
coasters and I have spent so much time
trying to get this child to
love herself
and her body and understand that all
right pause it there for a second
first of all where do you get off body
shaming that man
a very large man is that it's body
shaming first of all to say that
and second
everything we've heard so far
right it's like you have to wait till
you get to the conclusion where this is
all leading like the point that she's
trying to make
because what you've heard so far if this
was it I I would feel
sympathy it's like when you hear
um a uh an obese person on a plane and
the embarrassment of having to ask for
a seat belt extender or you know walking
onto the plane and knowing that
everybody's looking and thinking like oh
I hope that person isn't sitting next to
me that's that if you are the person
who's the target of of that uh that is
very difficult and I could have a lot of
sympathy
for you for that you know taking your
kid to
an amusement park and you can't fit on
any of the rides
it's humiliating it's depressing it's
disappointing you can't ride with your
child
so all of that
right
I sympathize
if
what you're leading up to is you saying
that well this is really difficult this
is a really terrible thing and so it's
it's made me realize that I need to lose
weight
okay if that's where all this leading I
would I would sympathize with what you
went through and I would have a lot of
respect for the fact that you've you
know you've confronted this situation
you've realized that you need to take
the bull by the horns here and take
control of your life take control of
your diet and all that and I I that's
all we would say about it
and you do hear this for these kinds of
stories sometimes for people who are
overweight overweight and especially
people that were you know very
overweight uh very unhealthy and then
they they had a dramatic turnaround and
if you talk to anybody like that
um they they almost always have a story
like this like a moment of
you know this kind of epiphany but not
that they didn't know that they were
overweight before but just a moment
where they're like this is it I can't do
this anymore
um and those stories again they're
they're sad but they also be
inspirational if they lead to a to uh a
turnaround
that's not where she's going though and
that's the problem
so let's keep watching a little bit of
this
everyone's body is capable of doing the
things that they want to do
and this was
extremely disappointing and very
humiliating
the next one that we tried was Hagrid's
magical creatures motorbike Adventure I
couldn't fit into either seat
um because they wouldn't lock over my
thighs
at that point I was
so humiliated that I didn't even try to
sit in the test seats for Harry Potter
and the Forbidden Journey I've ridden
this ride before did I want to ride in
with her of course
but I did not want to be humiliated in
front of hundreds of people sitting in
the test seat again I just
I couldn't do it
so we walked over to the Incredible Hulk
coaster which is one of my favorite
roller coasters ever I've ridden it
hundreds of times because I used to work
at Universal I didn't realize how small
the seats are and so I sat in the test
seat there
um and I was like sitting on top of the
seat so I tried the modified seat and
even that made my hips hurt so bad
um by the time we got through the line I
had decided not to ride because it was
very uncomfortable
I've recently been at Six Flags and at
Disney and I've had no problem with
coasters there I'm so disappointed and
Universal and okay there it is I was
waiting for that good well that's I
think we're here where's this all
leading it's like the whole the whole
sob story and uh and then where is it
going uh is it is it leading to oh my
gosh I've realized I can't even fit on
roller coaster rides with my child it's
getting it's this is this is not only
bad for my health but it's getting in
the way of of uh my life and it's
interfering with opportunities to bond
with my child I gotta take control I am
starting a diet I'm gonna start
exercising is it leading there no
instead it's leading leading to I'm so
disappointed in universal
so rather than this is from her
perspective rather than me making a
change and going on a diet I want
Universal Studios to redesign all of
their rides so that I can fit on them
right there's a problem here which is I
can't fit on the rides there are two
possible solutions one is that I gonna
diet and the other is that this theme
park completely rearrange everything to
accommodate me and of course she goes
with the latter option which involves
her doing nothing and everyone else
accommodating her
and but in the meantime anyway like even
if you're so unreasonable narcissistic
as to expect that to happen
what do you expect them to do in the
moment do you want them to if you don't
fit on the right you want them to put
you on the right anyway there was just a
case I think was last uh summer I forget
where it was but there was a a tragic
case of a young man I think it was a kid
actually a teenager who fell off of a
ride and was killed
and the reason they fell off is because
he was too big for the ride now to his
case it wasn't just like he was a big
person he was very very tall like a you
know kind of a football lineman sort of
size and they put him on the
on the ride even though he didn't fit
and he fell off and he was killed
so that's why they have the size
restrictions it's for your own sake if
they put you on anyway you could die and
that's gonna be terrible for you and
your family and also from the company's
perspective self-servingly uh they get
sued into Oblivion and so that's why
they're not going to do that so what do
you expect in the moment
what do you want them to do for you it's
just the rides are designed how they're
designed
do you want them to put your physical
safety
below as do you want them to to have
less concern for your physical safety
than for your emotional
well-being
you want them to prioritize your
emotional well-being of your physical
safety and then say well if it makes you
feel better go ahead and ride
and if you fall off and are killed
that's the answer yes she actually wants
that she wants her emotional well-being
to be prioritized over her physical
uh
safety but it's everyone else that needs
to prioritize her emotional well-being
not herself because there are things she
could do for her emotional well going on
a diet will also help her emotional
well-being but she's not going to bed
she wants everybody else to accommodate
okay
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
do you have a coffee lover on your
holiday shopping list Black Rifle has
all the best Brewing gear thermoses mugs
and Apparel Design for folks who love
country and coffee Black Rifle source is
the most exotic roasts from around the
globe all coffee is roasted here in the
US by veteran-led teams of coffee
experts so stuff your Christmas
stockings with the latest Rose from
America's coffee for 10 off with my code
Walsh better yet you can sign your
Secret Santa up for a coffee Club
subscription and imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roast when you need them most
it's the gift that keeps on giving Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated they take pride in serving
coffee and culture to people who love
America every purchase you make with
Black Rifle helps support veterans and
first responder causes so all you gotta
do is go to blackrifle.com use promo
code Walsh for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's
blackriflecoffee.com with promo code
walls for 10 off Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
Mark says aren't all crimes hate crimes
well no not not all crimes I got the
point you're trying to make but uh not
not every crime is necessarily a hate
crime you know there are crimes
motivated by uh by greed
crimes motivated you know by the crimes
of passion and so on so the crime's
motivated by lots of things but you're
correct that hatred this this is this is
the absurdity of the whole hate crime
idea
is that
um certainly with murder
you know it's it stands to reason that
hatred is involved in
most CR most murder like most murder
involves hatred
you're killing someone so it's pretty
obvious that you don't feel good about
them you don't like them
so whoever you're killing it's like it
stands to reason you probably hate them
so there's hatred involved in almost all
murder
and we end up with this ridiculous
situation where we're asking ourselves
well uh you know the the the mass
shooting at the gay club was this a hate
crime or not
of course it was a hate crime no matter
no matter why he did it like whether
whether he was a non-binary gay whatever
himself or if he was a right wing but
obviously he had hate in his heart for
the people that he was killing no matter
what
and what we're told is that as long as
he didn't hate them for being gay then
it's not as bad as if he did
why is that the case
what if he just what if he hated them on
a personal level what if he I'm not
saying I know this to be the case but
what if he knew them personally the
people that he targeted right let's just
say you know for for the sake of
argument and he hated them personally
because he was envious or jealous or
whatever it was he's carrying his own
resentment
is that not as bad as hating them for
their sexual orientation I would say
that it's
at least as bad
and splitting hairs here is ridiculous
so with the hate crime thing what we end
up with is when there's a murder not
only is has the court system put
themselves in the position
appearing inside someone's heart to
determine whether they had hate in their
heart while they did it which by the way
how could you possibly even prove that
but also then then once they've done
that now they're determining which kinds
of hatred are worse than others
it's ridiculous
it doesn't make any sense
and it also you know what else it
assumes that
hatred is the worst kind of like crimes
motivated by hatred are the worst kinds
of crimes of all
and I don't even think that's true
because you know the other thing that
could have motivated this this scumbag
yeah maybe he was enraged hateful very
very likely whatever they whatever was
the reason for the hatred it's very
likely
but then you also hear about mass
shootings
and and you hear from the from the I the
witnesses the victims that survived
and they they talk about what it was
like when they were there and oftentimes
they describe a mass shooter who's just
sort of casually walking around shooting
people almost like he looks almost bored
while he's doing it dead in the eyes
nothing there totally vacant
so you do have mass shootings where
someone's screaming and like spittle
flecked rage okay and that's and they're
fueled by hatred whatever's behind the
hatred they're fueled by hatred
there's a lot of mass shootings where it
seems that it's more that they're
motivated by total indifference to human
life
they can't even care about life enough
to hate people they can't even get to
that level totally indifferent these are
absolutely empty people who because they
don't care about human life at all
they're just killing people like it's a
video game and why are they doing it who
knows for for entertainment because you
know for for uh
to feel like some kind of power over
people to feelings whatever the
psychological thing is behind it
it's actually indifference that drives
it and I would argue that
people who are totally indifferent to
human life are actually even more
dangerous than people who are motivated
by hatred
but both are really really bad and as
far as I'm concerned the penalty should
be the same for both and the penalty
should be the ultimate penalty which is
which is death
all right uh BLK Hemi says child beauty
pageant should be added into this
discussion what about drag drag shows
well sure and you know this is always
brought up whenever we talk about the
child drag shows and people say what
about child beauty pageants yeah the
only reason we don't talk about those is
that uh number one thank God they're not
they don't seem to be nearly as common
these days and that's because number two
almost everyone now agrees thank God
that child beauty pageants are creepy
and weird and and there was a time when
they were popular and they had they were
reality shows about them but those days
are over now and like everyone agrees
right and left it's it's it's very hard
to find a defender of child beauty
pageants everyone agrees that it's just
creepy and weird and we shouldn't be
parading little girls around on stage
for that purpose
so we're in agreement there which is
good
the problem though is that people on the
left who will say that child beauty
pageants are creepy and weird
we'll make an exception for child drag
shows and so what they're saying is that
if you dress a little girl up all girly
and you prayed around on stage
that's creepy but if you dress a little
boy up in a girly way and prayed him
around on stage at a gay club when
people are throwing dollars at him
that's not creepy
so when it comes to the to the child
beauty pageant thing the contradiction
in hypocrisy as always is completely on
the left
uh
Alex says a few years ago before I left
the left I frequently attended drag
shows what really changed my mind about
them is when I witnessed a child putting
money in a drag queen's bra
while the mother cheered this on
it was disgusting and it's one of the
events that caused me to shift
politically
at least you had your eyes open and
you're willing to deal with what you
were actually seeing and think
critically about it so you deserve some
credit for that
you have a child putting a dollar bill
into a drag queen's bra and we're told
that
it's totally appropriate and is nothing
sexual about it
oh you know those those uh you know all
those completely non-sexual contexts in
which you would stuff money into
someone's underwear
you know happens all the time in a
non-sexual way
uh
and then Lynette says I would have
thought that Matt of all people would
understand the joy of getting heated
over some inconsequential Niche interest
fair enough fair enough I was getting on
uh you know Skip Bayless and Shannon
Sharp's case yesterday for screaming at
each other over a football game and
whether a quarterback played well or not
and uh they were there's more than one
person who pointed out that you know I
can tend to get heated and about things
that would seem to be rather
inconsequential
so maybe I should be more understanding
maybe you're right but actually but but
then again you're not and you're
actually banned from the show because
the things that I talk about are not
inconsequential oh what give me an
example give me an example on that of an
inconsequential thing that I have gotten
passionate about
you know or angry about on this show you
can't do it
what are you going to say shopping carts
well that's not inconsequential at all
as we have discussed many times
someone's putting an emoji up on the
screen emojis again this so uh uh emojis
shopping carts we're dealing with stuff
that that is that's a harbinger of total
civilizational collapse
so inconsequential I don't think so
the new daily wire Plus store is live
and it is your One-Stop shop for
everything worth giving because the fact
is nobody wants a copy of white
fragility that's not what they want they
just want something from dailywire.com
shop and they can pick up so many things
they're like a special deal on Johnny
The Walrus a book every kid should read
and every adult should read too grab one
of my limited edition sweet baby album
t-shirts or for the truly committed you
know who you are and you ought to be one
of them you should be you better be pick
up my Matt Walsh Super Fan bundle
shipping is free on orders over 75
dollars and with orders over a hundred
dollars you get a free leftist tears
tumbler skip cyber woke this uh holiday
and pick up gifts made exclusively from
truth so go to dailywire.com shop today
also the holidays are upon us and right
now there's never been a better time to
become a member of daily wire plus you
can watch what is a woman and everything
else we have for Less starting this
Friday because we've got a fantastic
Black Friday deal for you starting this
Friday you can get 50 off new daily wire
plus memberships and and gift
memberships 2022 was an amazing year not
only did I become a best-selling lgbtq
plus author with Johnny the walrus and
make a documentary that exposed a
transgender agenda become a women's
studies scholar and so many other things
but we also took the fight to the street
so to speak and uh we took some ground
with the rally to end child mutilation
we released Candace owens's documentary
the greatest lie ever sold and as if all
that was enough we signed Jordan
Peterson who has released a ton of
exclusive content already and this
Friday you'll be able to watch the first
two episodes of Exodus his brand new
16-part biblical series as well as logos
and literacy and Genesis all of that and
it also has a brand new introduction as
well a lot of great content from Jordan
Peterson that's a lot for a year but I
promise you it's only just beginning
we're building the future you want to
see we'll continue to do that in 2023 so
this Friday head to dailywire.com
subscribe to get 50 off your new daily
wire plus membership and come join us
now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
before we head into the Thanksgiving
holiday I must discuss something that
happened last week actually it's two
things both occurred during the Q a
portion of my speech at Berkeley on
Thursday night there are two people who
must be considered candidates for
cancellation as a result of the Q a and
since we've run out of time for the week
we have to cover them both in today's
daily cancellation and decide who's the
one who should get canceled so first we
start with a man named Jacob who to his
credit actually uh had the guts to
confront me on on camera during the Q a
over the course of our what is a woman
College Tour stopping at six or seven
different schools there were only two or
three leftists in the whole time who
dared to debate me in person and most of
the rest stood outside screaming holding
signs eating the Bible
in at least one case anyway Jacob was
one of the select few though
unfortunately he squandered the
opportunity by retreating and taking
cover behind a desperate appeal to
Authority as they so often do here's how
that conversation began
why in your movies and your discussions
be selectively ignore and misrepresent
the recent burjamin medical and
behavioral literature that demonstrates
uh that uh gender affirming care and
meds and similar medical interventions
demonstrate consistent improvements to
mental health suicidality and general
well-being
which study are those there are probably
like 30 Studies by this point all
produced in the last like 10 years or so
anybody can look them up on okay well
just here's here's the problem here's a
problem I'm not impressed
by just you saying a study okay because
studies fine well there could be 100
studies there could be a thousand
studies great yeah and actually I have
heard them have you yes I have okay so
here's I'll give you one example I don't
know if you can give me an example but
I'll give you one example of a recent
study that that uh and this was just in
the headlines it said that uh it proved
that um double mastectomies for minor
girls improves their well-being
and this was a study and it was proven
peer-reviewed
then you read what they how they
actually conducted this study and you
find out that they that they interviewed
a very small selection of girls in one
region of the country all from the same
socioeconomic background and they did
their follow-up I think it was
three months later
and based on a follow-up a few months
later they've determined that oh yeah it
improves well-being
you see the problem here no I don't want
I don't there are many but there are
this is the acceptance of the rule many
I don't think it is use observate use
observational data
um uh with various follow-up from like
six months to five years to ten years
and they don't demonstrate what you
claim
well I just you can say the word study
but what I'm saying is when you pick
them up okay great you can Google them
so he does a he's done a good bit of of
Googling he says
um and uh the only problem is that as is
usually the case when they start
babbling on about studies he cannot give
any specific examples which means that
he cannot defend the methodology used in
these studies all he knows is that the
studies were done and though he doesn't
know exactly what they say he knows that
whatever they say they vindicate
whatever he already thought before he
read the studies though he actually
didn't read them to begin with so to
review he brought up studies
but I'm the only one in the conversation
who could speak with any specificity
about any of the studies that he brought
up so the conversation continued until
um I got to what I think is the most
important Point here let's listen
how do you think they would have
large-scale long-term studies about the
effects of these drugs and these
surgeries on children when we only
started doing it to children at a large
scale a few years ago
so how could that even exist yeah I
think scale is probably one of the more
prevalent challenges of these studies
okay so we're already hearing that there
are challenges in these studies every
study has challenges like any scientific
truth like all of the scientific truth
that we take for granted today they're
built on methodologies that
fundamentally have flaws like if you
want to make a specific critique you can
do that if you're talking about I just
did well if you're talking about sample
size they're very well demonstrated
statistical results that you don't need
10 000 people to get like a significant
a statistically significant value yes
you do yeah absolutely not it's like a
very basic statistic Jacob
is greater than a thousand that can uh
like that has very nice asymptotic
properties like Jacob here's here's what
I know
if you want to even begin to claim that
a study has proven
that castrating and sterilizing little
boys helps them in the long run then you
would need to have a large sample size
of children who've gone through these
procedures and we've checked back with
them in adulthood to see how they're
doing those studies do not exist they
can't exist because we weren't doing
this to kids at anywhere near this scale
even five years ago let alone ten years
ago what that tells us Jacob is that the
kids we have right now they are the
sample okay they are the experiments we
are we are experimenting on children
right now
so right why aren't there any reliable
studies because the study is happening
right now today and the sample size is
an entire generation of kids
um Jacob and I continued for another
several minutes of course uh as I point
out to him later in the discussion the
whole focus on studies is a distraction
we don't need permission from a study to
arrive at certain common sense
conclusions one of those conclusions
that is that it is wrong to perform
cosmetic surgery on the sex organs of
children
and it's wrong to give them medically
unnecessary drugs that will permanently
hamper and destroy their physical
development so we can talk about the
studies and I can point out as I did
that the methodologies are flawed Beyond
repair but the truth is that there is no
study that would ever convince me that
we should castrate a child okay like
when someone asks me should we castrate
children I don't say well let me check
to see what the studies say I I just I
can say no to that the same way that if
you ask me should we shoot a child in
the head I would say
no and if you do you should be shot in
the head I don't need to check the
studies for that either directly and
intentionally harming children in these
barbaric ways is wrong
so he could produce a study with a
sample size of 50 000 which includes
follow-ups over the course of 30 years I
mean he can't because again that study
doesn't exist
but even if it did it would not move me
even one inch towards accepting or
supporting the physical mutilation of
children
I don't check with academics before
deciding whether I oppose child abuse I
just oppose it and I always will and
nothing can ever change that as I try to
explain
to Jacob eventually he just walked away
from the from the microphone when he had
enough I guess
so does Jacob deserve to be canceled
perhaps
but unfortunately someone else stepped
forward later on in the Q a who is even
more deserving of the cancellation
and that person is me uh
the time has come for the chancellor to
be canceled I have been slain by my own
cancellation sword
because of this
hello so I just saw people shouting in
like a bunch of barricades so I thought
it was fun to come here I didn't really
know who you were so before it started I
Googled you on Wikipedia I scrolled down
to the controversy section and it said
you said anime was satanic so I was one
all right
I was wondering if I bought your book
would you watch a season of any anime
with me
Collide How's that gonna work
um
Zoom
okay I hate Zoom meetings and I hate
anime now you want me to combine the two
okay okay and what am I getting out of
this I buy your book one book you gotta
buy a lot more books you have to buy
about about 100 books to make that worth
it so if we started a GoFundMe to buy a
hundred books you would live stream you
watching a season of anime
yes okay
all right don't all right
[Applause]
I am indeed the stupidest man on earth
and the worst deal maker in history
Donald Trump would be ashamed why did I
agree to that to an entire season of
anime an entire season not just one
episode a season
and instead of asking for like a
thousand books or ten thousand I agreed
to this torture for a measly 100 books
that that was by far the worst
negotiation I've ever witnessed I watch
and think who is this [ __ ] and then I
realize that the [ __ ] is me and I'm
filled not only with Dread but also
shame
I can only say it's a good thing that I
use a real estate agent instead of
making real estate deals on my own I'm
apparently the kind of guy who would
sell my house for like 50 bucks in a
Wendy's gift card only this is much
worse because as I've already
established anime is satanic so watching
an entire season of it certainly means
that I will become demonically possessed
so I have sold my soul here I've sold it
for a few books
I could have just done a like a hit on
Tucker Carlson you know and sold more
books than that
100 books
what what was I thinking I was not
thinking at all apparently
or or my thinking was impaired I was at
Berkeley after all maybe I was high from
all the second hand weed smoke in the
air maybe just two days in San Francisco
was enough to cause mental illness
I don't know how to explain it
now the good news is that technically
I never said when I would watch the
anime those details were never specified
I could schedule the live stream session
for like sometime in the year 2035 and I
would be I would not be violating the
terms of the deal if I did that
but the bad news is that apparently this
guy did already start the GoFundMe and
has raised almost immediately raised two
thousand dollars to buy the books so I I
had the the reason you might be asking
like why am I bringing this up now well
I held off on playing this clip in fact
I wasn't going to play it at all at all
because I was hoping that if I didn't
promote it or talk about it he wouldn't
be able to raise the funds because how
is he going to do that but um this has
taken on a life of its own and I am now
being swept along helplessly by the
current
and my destination is an entire season
of anime
and then as a result the loss of my
Eternal Soul I am a condemned man
condemned by my own suicidal negotiation
tactics
so all I can do now is call on the sweet
baby gang
in this time of Thanksgiving
to come to my Aid
and and tell me which anime has the
shortest episodes and shortest Seasons
ideally I'm talking about like I wanted
an anime that has three minute episodes
and three episodes per season
if such anime exists
and if it doesn't exist I need one of
you to make one okay I need this is this
this is the situation we're in right I'm
calling in a favor I am mobilizing sweet
baby gang I need you to make an anime
and put it on YouTube
season one of whatever thing anime
and and I'll and I'll watch it
only you can save me now
I certainly cannot save myself
because the day has finally arrived
when I must say that I am
canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you uh on Monday have a great
Thanksgiving Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]